j'ouvre tout de suite notre second débat
débat de société je vous propose de
revenir sur ce baromètre de sur le
sexisme publié par le Haut Conseil et
l'égalité c'était le 23 janvier dernier
un enseignement de cette enquête nous a
frappé nous a donné envie d'organiser ce
débat les jeunes de 25 à 34 ans sont
plus sexistes que leurs aînés les
détails les premières explications avec
Mathias Arès
5 ans après le mouvement me too où en
est le sexisme en France selon un récent
rapport du Haut Conseil à l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes la
situation est alarmante 93% des Français
estiment que les femmes ne sont pas
traitées de la même façon que les hommes
dans la sphère privée ou professionnelle
un problème pour Annick billon sénatrice
centriste et président de la délégation
au droit des femmes nous avons failli
dans les politiques publiques à mener
des politiques publiques pour plus
d'égalité que malgré la libération de la
parole et malgré les les nouvelles lois
qui qui normalement permettent je pense
forcément à l'égalité économique et
professionnelle avec
différents index différentes
politiques publiques différents lois et
bien malgré tous les efforts qui ont été
faits le sexisme perdure si l'on observe
plus de conservatisme au niveau des
rôles sociaux chez les 65 ans et plus
l'encrage des clichés masculinistes
passant chez les hommes de moins de 35
ans ainsi 20% des 25 34 ans considèrent
que pour être respecté en tant qu'homme
dans la société il faut vanter ses
exploits sexuels auprès de ses amis
contre 8% en moyenne pour la sénatrice
Laurence Rossignol ancienne ministre des
Droits des Femmes une partie de la
réponse à ce problème viendra de
l'éducation qui nous déjà nous
apprécions la loi et si la loi qui
prévoit que les élèves collèges lycées
ont trois ans d'éducation à la vie
affective et sexuelle était si cette
loi-là était respectée nous aurions déjà
un peu plus d'éducation dans son rapport
le Haut Conseil à l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes et mettent
également une liste de 10
recommandations parmi lesquels une
meilleure régulation des contenus
pornographiques en ligne ou encore une
augmentation des moyens de la justice
pour former les magistrats aux violences
intrafamiliales
je vous présente tout de suite les
invités de notre second débat Sylvie
Pierre Brossolette bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes président du Haut Conseil à
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
Arthur voit tout bonsoir bienvenue
maître de conférence en sociologie à
l'Université Sorbonne Paris Nord et
co-auteur de ce livre les jeunes la
sexualité et Internet aux éditions Les
pérégrine regenac bonsoir bienvenue
directrice de recherche CNRS au sévi pof
le centre de recherche politique de
Sciences Po et ce livre autrice de
radical et fluide les mobilisations
contemporaines publiées aux presse de
Sciences Po on va parler en général de
ce rapport mais on va commencer par les
jeunes il y a vraiment il y a pas que ça
on en est conscient et on parlera du
reste Sylvie Pierre Brossolette mais
quand même ce constat qui nous a frappé
est-ce qu'il nous a surpris aussi oui et
non on sentait bien que le cliché selon
lequel après mis tout les esprits
étaient tous à qui à l'égalité au
respect etc
ne touchez pas tout le n'est pas
forcément les jeunes puisqu'on voit ce
qui se passe dans les écoles dans les
grandes écoles on découvre que même un
Polytechnique les viols sont possibles
donc ce n'est qu'une confirmation
malheureusement de nos intuitions qui
avaient été déjà confirmé l'année
dernière on avait fait un premier
baromètre c'était le premier
qu'on faisait on s'est dit quand on a vu
les résultats on s'est peut-être trompé
il y a peut-être un bien méthodologique
on a affiné nos questions on a vraiment
essayé de compléter en plus le
questionnaire avec les questions sur le
consentement et rebelote ça donne
exactement la même chose plutôt empire
surtout sur le consentement donc
malheureusement effectivement
le sexisme est encore très présent
partout y compris chez des femmes
et la jeune génération malgré toutes les
évolutions en droit et en réalité il y a
quand même eu des progrès le droit des
femmes et le vécu des femmes mais ça
reste encore très très problématique et
chez les 25 34 ans plutôt pire
qu'ailleurs pourquoi cette génération là
on s'est demandé et on a des esquisses
de réponse on les a pas toutes les
chercheurs vont nous les apporter peu à
peu il me semble que c'est parce que
c'est la première génération de jeunes
adultes qui arrivent à cet âge en ayant
connu les réseaux sociaux le porno a été
baigné là-dedans depuis 15 ans et que
c'est une influence néfaste
parce que le sexisme il y a véhiculé et
la violence banalisée on y reviendra
évidemment on consacrera un chapitre de
ce débat à la question de l'influence du
des films des images pornographiques
Arthur veut tout est-ce que c'est notre
vision de la jeunesse qui était vous
l'avez un peu évoqué mais fausse ou
biaiser ou un peu un peu idéaliste sans
doute sans doute un peu on a tendance
depuis quelques années à présenter les
jeunes déjà à beaucoup homogénéiser la
jeunesse vers parler systématiquement de
la jeunesse en par exemple en réduisant
je sais pas où lutte écologistes ou à ce
genre de choses et je pense qu'il y a
toujours une sorte de petit voilà
présomption de progressisme déjà et je
pense que on se rend compte avec ce
baromètre mais avec d'autres enquêtes
aussi qu'en fait c'est faux c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a une part de la jeunesse qui
adhère encore fortement à des thèses des
idéologies conservatrices par exemple et
c'est vrai que c'est une jeunesse qui
existe et qu'on qui passe un peu sous
les radars comme ça parce qu'elle est
certes minoritaire mais elle existe et
puis il y a la jeunesse à l'épreuve de
la réalité je pense que le fait qu'on
parle là des 25 34 c'est les jeunes qui
entrent dans le marché de l'emploi qui
entrent dans des univers qui sont encore
des univers très fortement marqués par
le sexisme d'ailleurs c'est moins le cas
des plus jeunes qui sont pas encore tout
à fait rentrer dans cet univers donc
voilà il y a sans doute des choses à
regarder de ce côté-là ce rapport du
alors il y a ces rapports et baromètre
il y a ces cinquième rapport et puis il
y a le le baromètre
est-ce que pour vous ils permettent de
dépasser un certain nombre de mythes de
de la société française oui je crois
qu'on était jusqu'à présent dans une
logique assez dans un déni en fait dans
un déni puisque d'un côté on a quand
même des données qui objectives les
inégalités qui sont les conséquences du
sexisme
et dans toutes les secteurs de la vie
que ce soit la question des violences la
question des inégalités salariales et on
voit très bien aussi que même parmi les
jeunes et les petits on a des
orientations qui sont des orientations
encore très stéréotypées entre les
filles et les garçons et pour autant on
avait semis de les qualités déjà là sur
le fait qu'on était tous d'accord qu'on
était tous féministes qu'on était tous
pour l'égalité et qu'encore plus la
jeunesse ce n'était pas un sujet pour
eux est-ce que c'est le mouvement MiTo
auquel vous avez fait référence cette
libération de la parole qui est en cours
qui a pu accentuer ce cette impression
non moi je pense qu'il y a une forme de
de facilité à des politiser ces enjeux à
dire que nous sommes un qui exemplaire
alors qu'ils ont l'a rarement été on l'a
pas été historiquement sur ces sujets et
que on a juste un problème de mise en
oeuvre de comment et donc on a souvent
une tendance à dire d'un côté on a des
grands principes et puis on est tous
féministes et puis il y a quelques
marginaux qui sont violents quelques
dysfonctionnements il faut qu'on se
mette d'accord sur les meilleurs outils
là ce qu'on voit avec ce rapport je
trouve que c'est très intéressant parce
que ça nous montre la profondeur et la
gravité du problème c'est que non il y a
des divergences idéologiques sur ce
qu'on considère comme juste ou pas et
qui a par exemple un quart des hommes
qui considèrent que ils peuvent avoir
recours légitimement à la violence il y
a un tiers des femmes qui déclarent
avoir subi un rapport sexuel non
consenti c'est à dire avoir été violée
donc là on voit bien qu'on peut pas
répondre en disant la violence c'est que
le fait de marginaux ou d'impulsif non
il y a vraiment une normalité une norme
à la violence légitime
sur la division du travail et la manière
dont ça se répercute en termes
d'orientation scolaire en termes de
sectorisation des emplois entre les
femmes et les hommes quand on voit la
réponse sur les filles il est normal
d'élever des filles avec des poupées et
des garçons et des camions ou les femmes
sont naturellement douces donc nous
sommes au 21e siècle et il y a encore
13% je crois de la population des
personnes interviewées qui répondent ça
donc en fait là on voit bien que ça
aggrave le problème et que donc les
modalités à mettre en oeuvre sont plus
complexes aussi ce débat les clichés en
la peau dure parce que c'est quoi c'est
des siècles de de machisme qui qui
diffuse qui infuse depuis des
générations c'est aussi simple que ça
alors là je suis en train de relire
l'école des maris parce que je vais
faire un débat et on voit que Molière au
XVIIe siècle était beaucoup plus moderne
que nos contemporains et que dans dans
il y a deux il y a deux frères donc à
risque et xanarel scannerval et ce qui
est intéressant c'est que c'est le plus
jeune qui est le plus conservateur qui
qui trouve normal qu'on de choisir une
femme même si elle est pas consentante
voilà et le plus âgé dit en fait on ne
peut pas l'imposer de manière tyrannique
même si elle va devoir se marier avec
moi du fait de l'ordre paternel alors il
dit pas du patriarcat il dit de l'ordre
paternel pourquoi je cite Molière pour
bien montrer que l'un des mythes c'est
une pente naturelle vers le progrès donc
cette idée que parce qu'on est au 21e
siècle on devrait être plus donc là moi
je pense enfin je trouve que c'est très
intéressant d'avoir ce rapport qui nous
oblige à en effet avoir une position qui
est plus radicale au sens de comprendre
les causes pour agir efficacement pour
continuer sur Molière les Français sont
comme Monsieur Jourdain qui faisait de
la prose sans le savoir ils sont
sexistes sans s'en rendre compte c'est
en profondément ancré et ce n'est pas
parce que effectivement il y a une
égalité de droit la France effectivement
à peu près donne les droits égaux entre
femmes et hommes théoriquement et
et c'est très et c'est très récent et
donc les les mentalités les pratiques
n'ont pas suivi le droit quelquefois les
pratiques précèdent le droit ça arrive
que la société bouge plus vite que le
droit là le droit à bouger plus vite que
les pratiques et il y a des distorsions
et effectivement des des comme il y a
des problèmes annexes qui sont les
réseaux sociaux etc la jeunesse est
particulièrement touchée et donc on voit
bien qu'il y a un continuum dans le dans
le sexisme c'est ça qui est intéressant
je trouve dans ce rapport aussi c'est de
toucher du doigt du fait que les
violences n'arrivent pas toutes seules
il y a quelque chose qui fait le lit des
violences c'est une
quotidien
est-ce que tu as fait la cuisine pour ce
soir est-ce que tu es bien rentré ou
avec qui tu étais puis oh mais comment
être agacé filer une petite baffe et
puis ça finit peut-être quelquefois
beaucoup plus mal il y a un continuum du
degré de domination des hommes sur les
femmes pas toujours mais c'est comme ça
qu'on l'explique la violence n'arrive
pas toute seule elle arrive parce que on
se prend on se croit légitime pour
l'exercer et on ne fera pas baisser les
taux de féminicides en France donc on
n'aura pas aussi guéri les problèmes du
sexisme je quand même moi en préparant
ce débat je me suis dit il y a quelques
progrès c'est mon côté toujours un peu
optimiste qui s'exprime donc j'ai parlé
de la libération de la parole on peut
parler de la parité au sein des
gouvernements on peut parler des des
règles par exemple sur les comités de
direction ou les Comex des entreprises
qui qui instaure des quotas est-ce que
vous pensez à Arthur voit tout que
on surestime là aussi je parlais on a
peut-être un regard bien sûr la geste
est-ce que là on surestime ces progrès
ou est-ce que finalement on peut se dire
aussi être un peu positif c'est-à-dire
on a quand même un peu progressé oui en
tout cas on a progressé sur les discours
ça c'est sûr sur une séance sur une
échelle assez longue si on regarde les
enquêtes sur les valeurs des jeunes par
exemple et les valeurs des Européens de
manière générale on a des enquêtes
quantitatives de grandes enquêtes
aujourd'hui qui sont régulièrement
menées qui montrent depuis quand même
une vingtaine d'années une régression
des attitudes
hostile à l'égalité disons donc et c'est
vrai qu'il y a ce dont on parlait là à
l'égalité de droit globalement une part
croissante de la population qui
devient en tout cas favorable à
l'égalité salariale par exemple entre
les femmes et les hommes etc après il y
a la question des pratiques et c'est ça
qu'on a du plus de mal à sonder ont
sonde un petit peu avec ce type de
sondage là qu'on sonne par d'autres
enquêtes sociologiques par exemple mais
on a encore sans doute effectivement
beaucoup de phénomènes qui passent sous
les radars et je pense notamment
effectivement à ce sexisme d'ambiance
dont on parle là c'est le fait qu'on a
au quotidien alors ça peut passer on a
parlé de la pornographie tout à l'heure
mais il y a le sexisme publicitaire par
exemple il y a tout un tas de choses
d'ambiance comme ça il y a le fait que
par exemple la représentation politique
et encore une représentation malgré tout
très masculine que parfois on tolère de
la part de représentants politiques des
formes de sexisme très très
et donc je pense que tout ça ça
contribue à des pratiques du coup ce que
vous évoquez ça me fait penser à ce
compte Twitter qui s'appelle pépites
sexistes qui est donc recense voilà il y
a des hommes des femmes qui envoient ce
sur quoi ils tombent dans la rue et on
va voir quelques exemples on va voir des
médicaments voilà version homme la
version femme forcément la version femme
elle est rose puis accessoirement elle
est plus cher bon ben voilà on a aussi
les vélos qui sont roses forcément pour
pas leur nom d'abord oui alors ça c'est
un panneau de toilette et puis
évidemment quand il s'agit de changer de
changer bébé bah c'est forcément une
femme qui est représentée ou alors on a
dans une ancienne sportive Go Sport pour
ne pas la nommer des vélos roses avec
siège pour les poupées et puis les vélos
bleus forcément il y a un coffre comme
si c'était le vélo de papa qui va qui va
travailler bref ça peut nous faire
sourire évidemment regenac mais c'est
vraiment ce dont on parle c'est à dire
que là c'est ce qui nous environne une
certaine façon oui on voit une plus
qu'une résistance c'est à dire c'est
politique cette idée logique est-ce que
ça c'est politique et idéologique au
dessus finalement bon alors qu'est-ce
qu'on entend par terre qu'est-ce qu'on
entend par politique c'est le sujet si
on entend par politiques ceux qui dit le
juste ce qu'on considère comme juste
ensuite on peut l'associer à des
politiques publiques à des acteurs
politiques mais si on le prend de
manière très large sur ce qui dit le
juste qu'est-ce qui est dit là qu'est-ce
qui est dit il est dit que c'est
légitime d'élever les petites filles
pour qu'elles s'imagine comme étant de
futures bonnes mères voilà et alors que
les garçons vont être dans une autre
posture et ensuite on va construire
toute une mythologie de la liberté et de
la logique des choix éclairés par les
goûts
donc on va se dire ah bah c'est normal
qu'elle devienne qu'elle s'oriente
plutôt vers les métiers liés aux soins à
l'autre les enfants voilà parce que
c'est leur goût ah non c'est pas leur
goût ça a été construit depuis toute
petite par en effet le rapport loisirs
par les dessins animés qu'elle regarde
par la littérature par tout tout ce qui
fait socialisation donc et là où on peut
dire que c'est politique c'est que ça
porte et sa justifie sa légitime une
division du travail dans la sphère
privée dans la sphère publique trois
quarts des tâches ménagères à
domestiques sont faits par les encore
par les femmes c'est pas parce que
j'aime ça c'est parce qu'elles ont été
vraiment baignées dans cette normalité
là donc quand vous disiez on est
aujourd'hui à un moment de libération de
la parole
ce que disent les activistes c'est qu'on
est dans un moment de libération de
l'écoute c'est à dire quand cela on peut
se dire que ça a avancé c'est que il y a
des résistances il y a des
recompositions on peut même dire qu'il y
a des visions caricaturales et peut-être
même plus fortes c'est à dire que c'est
pas linéaire comme évolution dans les
répartitions des jouets par exemple mais
dans le même moment on voit autour à
partir de 2010 et ça c'est c'est
international c'est pas uniquement que
français et puis avec Me Too
c'est-à-dire que à la fois ça parle on
dit des choses il y a des brèches c'est
international et là les réseaux sociaux
peuvent avoir un côté positif il y a pas
que des côtés négatifs parce qu'on peut
passer des messages en dehors des
médiations classiques les partis
politiques les syndicats les assauts ça
passe direct donc ça bouge mais il y a
aussi une réaction c'est ça bien sûr
donc il y a un backlash ce qu'on appelle
un donc un retour de bâton en retour en
arrière donc le fait de se dire ça a pu
être audible c'est qu'en effet il y a eu
il y avait eu toute cette évolution
l'égalité de droit tout plein de
déclarations sur le fait que il y a
c'était une grande cause nationale enfin
donc il avez une préparation comme ça en
termes d'évolution donc les brèches ont
pu passer quoi que difficilement il y a
vraiment eu cette idée qu'on accusait
mis tout justement de pas passer par la
voie juridique si on passe pas par la
voie juridique et en fait elles sont
passées par la majorité parce que ça a
augmenté d'un tiers je crois les gros
con juridiques donc ça a normalisé aussi
le fait de faire des recours mais
c'était surtout que les plantes
n'aboutissaient pas donc il y a à la
fois ces mouvements là et puis un
mouvement de de résistance de recul donc
moi j'analyse aussi comme ça la
déclaration des 25 34 ans donc on voit
bien qu'il y a là une réaffirmation
virile face à quelque chose qui bouge et
qui alors qu'on a été élevé depuis petit
pour chacun avoir notre place notre rôle
là on nous dit que ça ça permet pas de
s'épanouir dans une logique égalitaire
qu'il faut déconstruire la domination et
on sent qu'il y a une réaction en fait
d'attachement à des rôles traditionnels
je vous propose un chiffre qui est
peut-être moins connu que d'autres qui
concerne la finance et les femmes
88% du total de l'argent levé en
[Musique]
une des petits détails comme ça depuis
le début les livres scolaires montrent
surtout la puissance des hommes à
travers les âges et les femmes sont
portion congrues donc il y a beaucoup de
détails qu'on peut changer dans
l'éducation il y a l'environnement
de stéréotype due aux médias au sens
large et en particulier internet et dans
Internet le porno parce que là vraiment
l'image des femmes est dégradée elles
sont violentées enfin c'est atroce donc
on va en parler mais quand même on monte
des images de sexe qui sont donc en
accès libre des 12 ans regarde ça on
montre des femmes massacrées et qui
après ont l'air ravi et qui disent ah
c'était merveilleux donc c'est vraiment
de de l'apologie de la violence comment
voulez-vous faire autrement donc il faut
réguler internet il faut interdire vous
ouvrez ce ce chapitre sur le les sites
porno avec je vais vous propose une
citation tiens pour commencer en 2023
c'est la fin de l'accès aussi de porno
pour nos enfants qui a dit ça c'est le
ministre délégué chargé du numérique
c'était dimanche dans le Parisien
Aujourd'hui en France on va évidemment
je vais vous donner la parole sur sur ce
qui pourrait changer mais d'abord le
constat 80% des mineurs auraient déjà vu
un film pornographique images vous
l'avez dit de plus en plus violente
sexiste mais aussi raciste qui ont
forcément un impact sur la sexualité des
jeunes mais aussi sur la place et
l'image des femmes dans ces générations
Hugo Lemonnier
majeur ou mineur il suffit d'un clic
pour accéder à ces millions de vidéos
selon une récente étude 80% des mineurs
auraient déjà vu un contenu un caractère
pornographique des scènes souvent
violentes devenues pour certains enfants
une référence en matière de sexualité
selon cette intervenante en milieu
scolaire par exemple une étude récente
de l'Ifop a sorti que 43% des
adolescents qui regardaient du porno
reconnaissaient reproduire dans leur
propre sexualité ce qui voyait dans le
porno or ce qui voit dans le porno c'est
de la violence c'est une manière de
percevoir la relation où il y a un
dominant et un dominé où il y a vraiment
cette logique d'utilisation de l'autre
pour son propre plaisir de performance
avec des sexes complètement refaits il y
a tout un univers qui qui est violent en
lui-même et qui est présenté à des
adolescents qui ne savent pas ce que
c'est que la sexualité la plupart du
temps les plateformes organisées en
catégorie structure désormais le marché
de la pornographie un monde où les
acteurs sont classés selon leur origine
d'ethnique beurette black wasiatique
quand le sexisme se conjugue avec la
mise en scène d'un racisme débridé ce
sont des hommes blancs qui échafaudent
les scénarios qui les construisent
à partir raciste préexistants sur
laquelle ils se font de l'argent l'arabe
la femme arabe soumise à vide de sexe ou
la haine par exemple à l'endroit des
femmes voilées ce qu'on peut avec l'idée
que une femme voilée on peut la violer
en faut la prendre et ce n'est en aucun
cas contrairement à ce qu'on dit des
consommateurs qui auraient des fantasmes
par rapport à une certaine catégorie
d'individus devant l'explosion des sites
pornographiques et les risques encourus
par les enfants le législateur a décidé
d'obliger les plateformes à mettre en
place un contrôle de l'âge de leurs
utilisateurs une mesure jamais appliquée
sommet de se conformer à la loi les
principales plateformes multiplient les
procédures judiciaires ils ont fait des
recours au Conseil d'État ils ont déposé
des questions prioritaires de
constitutionnalité tout ça dans un seul
but gagner du temps et je vous jure que
si la justice aujourd'hui faisait ce
qu'elle a à faire c'est à dire ordonner
le blocage des sites suite aux
procédures judiciaires qu'à initié
l'arcom je vous jure que les plateformes
à ce moment là bougeraient et trouverez
des solutions techniques pour
effectivement contrôler l'âge des
utilisateurs à 12 ans près d'un enfant
sur trois aurait déjà été exposé à des
contenus pornographiques
Sylvie Pierre Brossolette la France veut
donc c'est ce que le ministre délégué
Charlie numérique a annoncé imposé un
dispositif de certification de l'âge et
de contrôle parental par défaut pour
bloquer l'accès des sites pornos mineurs
là ce que j'entends dans le reportage
est-ce qu'il y en a vraiment besoin oui
ou est-ce qu'il faudrait pas tout
simplement commencer par appliquer la
loi non mais évidemment il faut
commencer par appliquer la loi il y
avait une procédure judiciaire faisons
là aller jusqu'au bout et ne changeons
pas de tactique en route enfin c'est de
la cuisine juridique mais l'essentiel
évidemment est de protéger les enfants
mais je pense que si on soigne le mal en
amont c'est à dire que si on évitait de
laisser en libre accès ces scènes
épouvantables il y aurait même plus de
problèmes d'enfants s'il y a pas que les
enfants qu'il faut protéger si vous
croyez qu'à 18 ans vous voyez ces scènes
épouvantables ou les reproduisez pas
dans votre vie ou même à 35 ou même à 45
on ne permet pas par exemple en France à
l'audiovisuel de montrer et c'est pas un
hasard des scènes de torture de ce genre
pourquoi est-ce que sur Internet on
aurait le droit de voir des ces scènes
de torture avec des femmes heureuses au
bout c'est de l'incitation à la violence
pure c'est une pure folie donc moi je
pense que il faut absolument réguler
internet il s'agit pas d'interdire la
pornographie il s'agit d'interdire la
violence la violence c'est quelque chose
de de
vraiment contre lequel il faut lutter je
pense que tout le monde peut être
d'accord là-dessus il peut y avoir un
consensus donc les scènes hyper
violentes de torture et de barbarie
devrait disparaître des écrans et
effectivement d'une part protéger les
mineurs en faisant appliquer la loi ça
fait deux ans que ça dure cette
plaisanterie on passe de procédure en
procédure arrêtons les frais et que la
justice enfin prenne ses responsabilités
parce que là aussi chez les juges il y a
encore du sexisme et des vieux
conservatismes on dit auront c'est pas
bien grave c'est du porno vous savez
combien
de de
condamnation sont prononcés par an il y
a 90 000 femmes qui se plaignent de viol
ou de tentatives de viol chaque année il
y a 783 condamnation et seulement une
trentaine de peine de prison voilà c'est
ça la justice donc par tous les bouts il
faudrait renforcer le dispositif donc
interdire les scènes de violence
effroyables sur Internet renforcer la
justice former les juges et l'éducation
évidemment pour les générations à venir
je vais vous donner deux chiffres l'un
qui qui émanent de votre baromètre 48%
des hommes entre 15 et 40 et 34 ans
considèrent que l'image des femmes
véhiculées par les contenus
pornographiques et problématiques donc
ça c'est pour la jeunesse 48% alors que
c'est 79% pour les hommes âgés de 65 ans
et plus
il y a un problème et puis autre chiffre
mais là qui nous vient de
Grande-Bretagne un autre rapport
47% des personnes interrogées estiment
que les filles s'attendent à ce que les
rapports sexuels impliquent de la
violence Arthur va tout on peut enfin
voilà si lui Pierre Brosset vient de le
détailler mais ce lien entre
les sites les images pornographiques et
une vision finalement totalement biaisée
de la sexualité on peut le faire alors
on peut le faire c'est une question
qu'on se pose souvent effectivement
est-ce qu'il y a un lien entre ce que
les jeunes notamment vont visionner et
ce qu'ils vont mettre en pratique dans
leur dans leur sexualité alors déjà
juste peut-être c'est pas pour
relativiser du tout mais juste de dire
on a tendance à parler des enfants à
dire les enfants sont exposés et c'est
vrai c'est vrai que les enfants peuvent
être exposés à ces contenus et ça pose
un problème évidemment après quand on
fait des enquêtes auprès des jeunes
directement quand on leur demande à quel
âge ils ont vu leur premier porno on
n'est pas tout à fait dans les chiffres
que souvent font remonter ces sondages
là parce que alors dans les sondages les
jeunes et répondent oui à 10 ans j'en ai
vu un quand on leur dit mais c'était
quoi 10 ans souvent c'est l'image d'un
film qui les a choqués etc ils étaient
pas forcément directement sur les sites
dont on a pu voir là des extrait flouté
tout de suite et surtout ils sont pas
forcément tout de suite dans une
pratique régulière du porno etc donc
voilà juste pour dire c'est
principalement les adolescents qui vont
voir du porno parce que c'est valorisé
aussi dans la cour de récré dans la cour
du collège oui mais on y a consacré un
débat le porno d'aujourd'hui c'est pas
du tout celui qui dit bien sûr la
violence elle est omniprésente elle est
très accessible et c'est vrai que par
mots clés par exemple on peut trouver
le pire de ce qu'on peut trouver sur
internet mais je pense que la question
de l'influence par contre il y a
plusieurs choses à en dire une des
choses qui je pense est importante c'est
de dire d'abord que les périodes de
visionnage intense de pornographie par
les jeunes en général sont assez
découlés de l'entrée dans la sexualité
parce qu'en réalité il regarde beaucoup
de porno au début du collège des années
collège notamment 11 12 13 ans c'est pas
tout à fait l'âge d'entrer dans la
sexualité qui arrive un petit peu après
donc déjà voilà pour pas dire les
phénomènes n'arrivent pas tout à fait en
même temps c'est à dire qu'ils ont le
temps parfois de prendre un peu de recul
nous on a vu des jeunes on entretient
avec ma collègue Yaël amsellemengui à
qui on a posé cette question de
l'influence et qui nous disent c'est
vrai quand j'ai regardé mes premiers
pornos par exemple je pensais que le
corps devait être systématiquement
toujours entièrement épilé je pensais
que je pouvais faire telle ou telle
pratique sans demander
c'est pas pour là encore pour
relativiser mais il faut quand même
voilà être un peu plus proche de des
pratiques réelles des jeunes
heureusement parfois la confrontation
avec la sexualité elle-même leur premier
rapport sexuels viennent un peu
déconstruire des mêmes enfin faire
dégonfler comme ça c'est représentations
parfois très violente qu'ils peuvent
avoir eu voilà après je pense que il y a
la question évidemment de l'éducation
dont on a déjà parlé c'est à quel point
l'éducation va permettre de déconstruire
ou pas et on sait que c'est pas le cas
pour tous les jeunes dans toutes les
conditions et ça c'est une vraie
question pour le coup de l'éducation à
la fois officielle et l'éducation des
parents parce que j'ai aussi des gamins
ont accès porno c'est quand même on peut
interdire ça par la loi mais j'associe
une responsabilité parentale je veux
bien que le téléphone
aussi pour revenir au sujet de
l'éducation quand on pose la question à
des jeunes mais pourquoi aller sur
internet voir des images pornographiques
on pourrait imaginer que c'est d'emblée
la curiosité sauf qu'en fait on a des
jeunes qui nous répondent mais c'est
parce que j'ai envie de voir à quoi
ressemble un corps et en fait on ne l'a
jamais montré on ne l'a jamais montré
parce que par exemple l'éducation la
sexualité qui se fait en milieu scolaire
elle est pour le dire extrêmement
gêné policier c'est à dire les
enseignants ont peur d'aller dans le
sujet et peu de gens sont formés en fait
à éduquer à la sexualité et en fait les
jeunes ne trouvent pas ce qu'ils
cherchent ils trouvent pas ce qu'ils
cherchent dans l'éducation la sexualité
à l'école donc ils vont chercher
ailleurs ils vont chercher des images
ailleurs et il se trouve que parfois ces
images sont violentes et c'est ça sans
doute le problème je ne sais laquelle
est-ce que vous faites le lien entre
voilà ce ce ces images pornographiques
on l'a dit de plus en plus
violentes et qui se racistes et le
sexisme au quotidien dans la dans la
société française ça fait système c'est
certain et quand on voit le chiffre de
47% des femmes qui qui s'attendent à à
avoir des rapports violents on voit bien
que il y a un phénomène qui est de
normalisation des violences aussi bien
du côté des hommes que du côté des
femmes qui intègrent aussi cette réalité
là donc on dit souvent que l'imaginaire
et la réalité bien sûr on parle beaucoup
de récits en politique les les
politiques partent toujours de cette
nécessité de faire de refaire un récit
et là on voit bien que c'est en plus un
récit qui est incarnait qui est visuel
et qui dit en effet une réalité qui
envisageable et puis on voit en plus ce
croisement entre la dimension sexiste
raciste qui est quand même quelque chose
de très de très choquant et et qui
montre que on est encore dans dans des
catégories qui sont des catégories là
qui sont assumées dans une logique de
business et se dire que ça permet de
faire du business d'avoir de travailler
sur et de conforter de normaliser le
sexisme et le racisme il est certain que
là et moi je trouve que le parallèle
avec ce qu'on ne permet pas dans l'accès
violence pour les autres types de
violence il est intéressant c'est à dire
qu'on se dit
féministe portant l'égalité femme et on
va permettre qui est une socialisation à
la violence en accès libre alors qu'on
va penser que c'est complètement hors de
notre portée d'avoir une socialisation à
la violence pour toutes les autres types
de violence alors on va parler politique
maintenant il nous reste une dizaine de
minutes dans ce débat je propose à Steve
Jourdain de nous rejoindre tout de suite
sur ce sur ce plateau bonsoir Steve bien
bienvenue on pourrait on va démarrer
avec une question toute simple est-ce
qu'il y a toujours du sexisme en
politique bah non non tout ça c'était
dans le monde d'avant on se rappelle par
exemple cette séquence célèbre en 2012
Cécile Duflot ministre du Logement avait
eu ce jour-là la très très mauvaise idée
de porter une robe à fleurs dans
l'hémicycle regardez
madame Cécile Duflot ministre de
l'Égalité des territoires et du logement
monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les députés mais
surtout messieurs visiblement toujours
dans le monde d'avance rappelle aussi de
cette députée l'écologie
Massonneau en pleine prise de parole
elle se fait interrompre par des
imitations de poules
c'est bon
évidemment ce ne sont des choses qui
n'arrivaient qu'à l'Assemblée nationale
pas au Sénat jamais jamais le Sénat a
toujours été épargné par le phénomène la
preuve en image regardez vous venez de
dire à mon propos pendant que je parlais
de la parité c'est qui cette nana je
souhaite que ce soit bien inscrit votre
nom s'il vous plaît monsieur sido mais
je crois que vous avez gagné peut-être
ce matin la palme du misogyne bof de
cette assemblée
en réalité Assemblée nationale et Sénat
même combat droit de gauche même combat
le sexisme touche les deux assemblées et
tous les bords politiques de la même
façon il peut même parfois venir du
gouvernement écouter en l'occurrence aux
personnes elle est très rapide et un peu
populiste et c'est la difficulté essayez
de démontrer
aujourd'hui il y a une baisse de 30%, ça
va bien se passer
Emmanuel Macron avait fait de l'égalité
homme-femme la grande cause de son
premier quinquennat mais quand on se
penche sur les chiffres on est encore
loin du compte le réseau est lu local a
mené une étude en 2021 le sondage parle
de lui-même trois femmes élues sur
quatre disques avoir un jour été
confronté à des remarques ou à des
comportements sexistes ça comprend des
interruptions lors des prises de parole
des attitudes paternalistes des blagues
ou des remarques déplacées toujours
selon cette étude 20% des élus
interrogés disent avoir subi des
remarques liées à leur apparence
physique l'atmosphère est tellement
hostile qu'une élue sur trois a déjà
pensé à abandonner la politique à la
suite de comportement sexistes c'est
dire Thomas l'ampleur du phénomène alors
quand on demande aux femmes politiques
si les choses vont quand même mieux bien
oui elles vont mieux qu'il y a quelques
années la réponse est oui mais il reste
encore beaucoup de chemin à faire en
termes de parité par exemple Parlement
penche toujours clairment du côté des
hommes à l'Assemblée nationale on compte
37% de femmes au Sénat on est seulement
à 35%. merci beaucoup Steve Jourdain
pour pour tous ces éléments au niveau
local tiens je vous propose une réaction
maintenant la députée modem Sandrine
Josso co-fondatrice des Simon c'est une
association qui veut casser le plafond
de verre des femmes en politique elle
nous donne des chiffres au niveau local
regardez 80% de mer aujourd'hui sont des
hommes
89% de présidents de communauté
d'agglomération ou de communes sont des
hommes et
malgré la parité
donc en fait finalement on se dit que
c'est une parité qui est
comme une illusion
de ces instances là c'est Pierre
Brossolette si on cherche un peu des
solutions dans le monde politique il y a
les quotas qui ont été imposés les
partis politiques les respectent pas
toujours ils préfèrent parfois payer des
des amendes quelles solutions
sur la parité en décembre au FCE qui
propose des solutions pour qu'il y ait
la parité à l'Assemblée nationale on a
un système simple c'est adopté à
l'Assemblée nationale le système des
conseils départementaux vous connaissez
bien au Sénat c'est à dire le système
binominal majoritaire c'est à dire qu'à
chaque fois dans chaque circonscription
il y a un homme et une femme qui sont
élus donc forcément il y a la moitié de
femmes et d'hommes à l'arrivée il y a
des exemples comme ça mettre au défi les
gouvernements enfin dans l'obligation
les gouvernements de ne pas nommer
simplement 50% de titulaires mais de
regarder qualitativement quels sont les
postes ne pas mettre aujourd'hui 4
ministres hommes sur cinq pour les
ministères régaliens et 9 de femmes
secrétaire d'État sur 10 pour les
ministères les moins importants il y a
plein de petites règles qu'on pourrait
mettre en route mais c'est vrai que
beaucoup de femmes sont découragées
d'entrer en politique tant qu'il y a ce
matchisme bien qu'il faut évidemment
combattre c'est un tout comme
dirait-jeanne et c'est systémique et la
politique en est une caricature vivante
c'est pas ça a été tellement longtemps
le domaine purement des hommes que
c'est très très difficile pour les
femmes de s'y faire une place ne
serait-ce que les horaires les les
habitudes c'est c'est ce Boyz club que
constitue les partis politiques ou les
investitures sont tenus généralement par
les hommes il faut changer tout ça peu à
peu la loi y aide il faut passer
maintenant un acte 2 de la parité et
prendre l'autre partie des mesures qui
sont nécessaires alors comment ça se
passe au plus haut sommet de l'État
Mathieu le président de la République
est-il sexiste je me suis posé la
question parce que c'est quelque chose
qu'on entend souvent et puis si on en
croit l'Observatoire des violences
sexistes et sexuelles en politique la
réponse est oui trois fois oui la même
reçu en novembre dernier avec Jean-Luc
Mélenchon le prix du parrain ils étaient
tous les deux colorias qui distingue
selon les organisateurs ceux qui ont
vaillamment protégé leur poteau leur
ministre leur Bros et qui leur ont
assuré une immunité face au tribunal
médiatique comme il l'appelle ou au
tribunal tout court et de reprocher au
chef de l'État d'avoir abrité dans ses
gouvernements Nicolas Hulot Damien Abad
ou encore gendarmanin leur rappelle que
si les deux premiers font face à des
accusations ils ne sont plus au
gouvernement et que quand au troisième
il a été blanchi à bénéficié d'un
non-lieu confirmé en appel même si la
plaignante se pourvoit en cassation
alors ce prix du parrain évidemment
satirique il n'engage évidemment que ces
organisateurs qui comptent il faut le
dire bien peu de macronistes dans leur
rang l'Observatoire sexuelle et sexiste
en politique mais si cela peut faire
sourire ou grincer on peut se poser la
question de savoir si c'est légitime ou
non et là évidemment c'est toujours
beaucoup plus nuancé contrasté parce que
la réalité elle est rarement noire ou
blanche si on regarde par exemple que ce
soit sur les symboles ou dans sa
politique sur les symboles tout d'abord
les postes clés de la macronie
aujourd'hui sont détenus par des femmes
il y a une première ministre il y a une
femme qui préside l'Assemblée nationale
il y a une femme qui est présidente du
groupe
présidentielle à l'Assemblée nationale
alors toutes n'ont pas été nommé
Emmanuel Macron tout au moins pas été
poussé ou promu Macron mais enfin ça
n'était jamais arrivé avant il y a en
revanche c'est vrai que si on regarde le
gouvernement on regarde les poids lourds
les portefeuilles regardiens ben c'est
plutôt des hommes que vous avez là que
ce soit Gérard Darmanin à l'intérieur
Bruno Le Maire à Bercy Eric
Dupont-Moretti et la justice bref je
vous fais pas la liste vous les
connaissez si on regarde aussi le
cabinet du président analysé bah là il y
a quand même deux tiers d'hommes pour
pour un tiers de femmes et alors sur la
politique alors là c'est c'est plus
compliqué aussi parce que c'est des
appréciations le sexisme ce sont des
données objectives et factuelles mais
c'est aussi une perception et c'est
aussi parfois
le jugement de valeur donc il y a quand
même ce choix cet accent qui a été mis
sur la cause de l'égalité entre les
hommes et les femmes et sur la lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
par par Emmanuel Macron et toute une
série de lois qui ont été adoptées dont
la loi renforçant l'action contre les
violences sexistes et sexuelles en 2018
la loi de programmation et de réforme
pour la justice en 2019 la loi visant à
agir contre les violences au sein des
familles en 2019 je vous fais pas le
tout le topo de ce que contiennent ces
lois et sans doute cette insuffisant
mais enfin il y a quand même eu des
choses il y a une loi visant à protéger
les victimes de violences conjugales
aussi en 2020 il y a des moyens qui ont
été mis ces symboliques mais le budget
du secrétaire d'État qui est devenu un
ministère de l'égalité homme-femme a été
doublé alors il a plus de missions mais
il a été doublé l'état fait savoir
qu'après 1 milliard qui est
mobilisé pour la cause de l'égalité
homme-femme quand on regarde dans le
détail s'aperçoit que ça part beaucoup
dans tous les sens il y a des outils
quand même qui ont été mis en place que
soit le 39 19 la création de plus de
3000 places d'hébergement
supplémentaires pour pour les femmes
enfin le développement du 39 la création
les places d'hébergement supplémentaires
pour les femmes victimes de violence le
lancement de plateforme internet la
création de l'infraction d'outrage
sexiste puis voilà des la multiplication
des ordonnances de protection
développement du téléphone grave danger
je pourrais le bracelet anti
rapprochement tout ça a été mis en place
ça n'a pas empêché bien sûr des
violences sexuelles et sexistes de ce
perpétrer ça n'a pas empêché dans
certains cas même qu'elles augmentent
mais voilà la réalité elle est nuancée
c'est toujours évidemment difficile de
donner à quelqu'un un qualificatif c'est
un comportement qui est sexiste c'est
pas quelqu'un rejette
alors je citerai peut-être un chiffre
sur la lutte contre les violences en
Espagne c'est 16 euros par personne par
an en France et 5 euros par personne par
an donc je pense que là tout ce dont on
a parlé c'est la question de la
cohérence comment est-ce qu'on peut
proclamer l'égalité famme grande cause
nationale demanda de suite et dans le
même moment
comme le disait déjà les suffragettes
être dans les dans les promesses et pas
dans les actes on voit bien les les
associations féministes et les
travailleurs sur le terrain
dénonce ce hiatus donc bien sûr qu'il y
a eu des lois il y en a à chaque fois la
question c'est comment est-ce qu'on fait
en sorte de les déjà de les appliquer
des appliquer pour l'outrage sexiste
sans que ce soit un moyen de
disqualifier et d'aller dans les plus
faibles qualifications et puis sur la
lutte contre les violences il y a un
vrai problème et quand compare avec
l'Espagne c'est quand même du simple au
et en Espagne ça fait reculer le nombre
de féminicides donc on voit bien quand
même que ça a été associé à une
éducation non sexiste il y a eu une loi
ce qu'on appelle une loi cadre mais
aussi des moyens qui ont été mis en
oeuvre
et plutôt voilà ils sont mis plutôt et
s'ils sont mis en donnant les moyens
donc moi je crois qu'il y a vraiment une
nécessité de cohérence de cohérence on
l'a vu individuelle mais aussi de
cohérence politique et collective merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat je vais rappeler le titre de
les titres de vos livres Arthur voit
tout les jeunes la sexualité et Internet
qui est publiée aux éditions Les
pérégrines et regenac radical et fluide
les mobilisations contemporaines
publiées aux presse 2 Sciences Po merci
encore je vous dis à demain pour un
nouveau numéro de sens public et votre
prochain rendez-vous politique sur notre
antenne Laurent marchandelli le
président du groupe horizon à
l'assemblée qui sera l'invité Dorian
Mancini à 8 heures demain matin belle
soirée
[Musique]